I know London people pay a lot of money
to get hot dog what we'd wanna do you
get make up about is connect
kinda bother your friends with we do
this what back until he said
[Music]
solids back on summers you know this is
with Shane Hill
this [ __ ] foudre what bad things have
changed I'm running the first time no
[ __ ] that
ain't nobody gonna try to travel summer
house Jamie yeah let me give you a piece
of advice you're here to get mine you
want to sell food we saw my food you're
not so nothing up all do we lava it's
got them two brothers yet I'll just do
we do you provides for us doesn't it
surprise
these are yo who I meet Oh nah
ever since we were kids for us together
running up and down these streets trying
to get to the top to do that we have to
contain the other way
Lattimore
[Music]
ain't no trust in this case I trust you
to do the right thing
whatever mindset to get to Tokyo to
fight for what you want find you know 30
it's up
it's worth using the pupil
thumbs
well so we gonna be
[Music]